Fury
Why haven't
you called any of your special friends
You're out of moves, Fury.
This is a ticking time bomb.
You've got to figure out which side
you're on.
Well.
My mom always said I was special.
Marvel Studios Secret Invasion
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie, Happy Comic-Con Week!
This will be my Secret Invasion
Episode 6 Finale Trailer.
There's a bunch of Easter eggs,
obviously a couple
really big storylines
that they have to wrap up.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we have.
The Loki series is coming pretty soon.
We're supposed to get a trailer for that
this weekend.
I don't know
if they're going to wind up releasing it
because Marvel changed
all their Comic-Con plans.
But they are releasing a brand new trailer
for the Marvels movie,
and they'll probably be
a post-credits scene
at the end of Secret Invasion Episode
six They'll explain what's happening
at the beginning of that movie.
my early theory right now
is it will either involve Monica Rambeau
in the Sabers space station,
like they'll end the series
with Nick Fury
going back to the Saber space station
because that's where he is
when the Marvel's movie begins.
or they might just play the Miss Marvel
Post-Credits scene for just a little bit
more like what happens immediately
after the Miss Marvel Post-Credits scene
where Captain Marvel had switched places
with Kamala Khan
because of the way her powers
worked in combination with the bangle.
she's swapped places with Kamala Khan
and she had formerly been in
another part of the galaxy
with increased role space on a cruise ship
in when she shows up in Kamala
Khan's bedroom,
she has absolutely no idea
what's going on.
Like, how did I get here in
Is this a stalker's room?
Just because there's pictures of her
all over the place,
what they might do is just show you
what happens immediately after this scene.
Like she probably tries to contact
Nick Fury
because she finds out to shoot back on her
like she runs downstairs and finds
Kamala Khan's parents. And they're like,
What the hell is going on here?
So she contacts Nick Fury
and that's how he winds up at her house
in Jersey City with Monica Rambeau.
I also think there's
going to be a post-credits scene
or some kind of teaser at the end,
like just the last couple of scenes
where they explain
what happens with the real Rhodey,
How long he's been gone this whole time.
Like which movie exactly?
It was when he got switched end.
It'll help
set up the Iron Man Armor Wars movie
that they're doing in Marvel Phase six
Previously
that movie was supposed to come out
right after the new Fantastic Four movie
that might wind up swapping places
a little bit because of all the delays
that have been happening recently.
but supposedly
after they rescue the real Rhodey
from this giant stash of people
that they've been keeping on ice
like you see in the trailer here,
she finds all these bodies of world
leaders.
Important
figures at the schools are replaced
the real Rhodey learns that Skrull Rhodey
secretary has been using his status
as war machine his access
to all the Iron Man stark tech
to do all kinds of shady stuff
all around the world.
And because of what the skrulls were doing
with all that Iron Man tech,
it falls into the hands
of a bunch of villains.
it also winds up getting into the hands of
people like Val in damage control.
We already saw that during Spider-Man,
No Way Home. And then during the Ms..
Marvel series with them
using the stark tech.
Edith Drones in the Real Rhodey.
We'll just have to deal with that,
clean up that mess.
During the Armor Wars series with Justin
Hammer coming back to work for Val, create
more new Iron Man armor tech in things
based on Iron Man's designs.
basically like a bigger, worse
version of what he did in Iron Man two.
mean, I had an army of robots.
What's he got? He's got some dumb accent.
His name's Trevor.
And what does that mean?
Like bin Laden and Benny Hill had a baby
part of that will also borrow
from comic book armor wars.
The only difference is obviously it's
Rhodey
taking the lead instead of Tony Stark,
Iron Man, instead of just a blanket U.S.
government being one of the major
antagonists with Justin Hammer,
damage control
winds up being more of the main villain
because Justin Hammer
is creating all the new Iron Man armor
tech for them during the comic book armor
wars, the U.S.
government basically commissions
this giant Iron Man armor design.
That Iron Man winds up having to take down
they'll probably have a version of that
during the Armor Wars movie.
But it's just an hammer who created it
for damage control and rhodey's.
The person that has to destroy it
supposedly during that movie
because of all the Iron Man armor tech
that Val and damage control are messing
with or Justin Hammer at least is messing
with, they bring back Ultron
unexpectedly, like they accidentally
reactivate the Ultron protocols.
But like I said, even though you
normally would think Ultron would be
the villain of a movie like that
or the resurrected Ultron, technically
it'd be damage control
because they're the person
that are pulling all the strings
a lot of what happened
during that movie will be under
the purview of President Thunderbolt Ross
So we'll see what happens to him
at the end of this series
or how they explain him
becoming president.
The United States
in President Ritson Either leaving office
or being voted out of office.
That might have something to do
with the harvest storyline.
The whole idea of grafting people's
powers on you're like taking the Avengers
powers.
Val would definitely want something like
that, like she wants all the vibranium
from what Conda
during Captain America four They also want
the adamantium that gets found on team.
Its body.
but suddenly they had this cachet
of all of the Avengers
DNA in a way to give themselves powers.
so I wouldn't be surprised if the U.S.
government Val Thunderbolt Ross
tried to get their hands on the Skrulls
Super Skrull technology
at the end of the series.
during the footage from the actual episode
in the trailer, we see Nick Fury taking
what gravik thinks is the harvested
Avengers DNA to his base in Russia.
It looks like they get into an actual
fight in the reactor room
where they built that super skrull device
there's no way that Nick Fury
would have a chance against gravik.
Like gravik looks all Hulked out here,
like he's giving himself the coal
obsidian power.
So he's super strong and super durable,
technically,
it would be like the powers of the thing.
If we're talking about analogs
for the fantastic force powers.
a lot of people
also wondering if because of this fight,
the point of finding out that Nick
Fury himself is not the real Nick Fury,
you know,
some secret replacement like a
like model decoy or he's secretly a skrull
pretending to be Nick Fury again
just based on the way they're
presenting the fight in the trailer.
Like without any extra footage.
This seems like the real Nick Fury.
Like, he definitely gets his ass
handed to him end.
I think his quote during episode five,
about the only thing that his mama
really left him was the brain between
his ears was meant to be foreshadowing
for the way that he takes gravik
that like he outsmarts him,
he doesn't beat him in a one on one fight
because there's no way
that he has a chance of doing that.
the other weird line of dialog,
the gravik had when he and Nick
vary were trading barbs
is that he implied that Nick Fury
when he brought the Avengers harvested
DNA, would get a giant dose of radiation
poisoning
when he came to that reactor room.
that might be part
of how the super skrull device works.
Like they dose themselves
with a bunch of radiation
while they're mutating their DNA
with this other superpowered person, DNA,
there's an old joke about Stan
Lee based superheroes,
like the characters that Stanley created.
A lot of them either got their powers
by being dosed in radiation, toxic waste,
bitten by radioactive spiders,
having stuff dumped on them,
being bathed in cosmic radiation,
basically some type of radiation
equals powers in their
making all these sly Fantastic
Four references and Easter eggs
with some of the story details
during the series.
That's basically how the fantastic Four
got their powers.
They were caught in a solar storm
and bombarded with cosmic radiation.
there was this joke about Darwinism
in evolution.
There's the whole idea of mutants
being the evolution of the human race.
I don't think we're going to see
a ton of mutants or X-Men characters
during the finale or anything like that.
but it does sound like
they're laying the seed,
like they're laying the groundwork
for more mutants popping people in the MCU
getting their DNA mutated
like Monica Rambeau had her DNA mutated.
The interesting thing about mutants
X-Men characters is that technically
when you get your DNA mutated, you're
actually called a mutant, not a mutant.
Traditional mutants in the MCU,
like the distinction is the yet to be born
with those powers, born with the x gene,
basically, that's my characters
like the Hulk and Spider-Man
that have biologically
based powers are technically mutates
in characters like Kamala Khan. Ms..
Marvel in the MCU, who were born with
their powers, are traditional mutants.
X-Men are also a little bit different.
And then they're just a particular group
of mutants in the comics.
In order to be called an X-Man.
Normally you have to have been on the team
at some point.
But usually when people are talking
about X-Men characters in general,
people are just referring to anyone at all
who was featured in the X-Men comics.
At some point.
Like technically,
Scarlet Witch is an X-Men character.
Even though she's more of an Avengers
character,
Just based on what Elizabeth Olsen
has been talking about recently.
They'll get into the whole Scarlet
Witch Mutant X-Men thing
during Deadpool three and future movies
that she ends up appearing in. but.
I don't think they're creating
a whole bunch of mutants
during the series or anything
like that. Would not be surprised, though.
The Skrulls learn
how to mutate DNA to give people powers,
and that's something
that other MCU characters like
Val would want to get their hands on
and use it in the weapons Plus program.
sort of the way the Captain America
super soldier serum evolved
into that upgraded form during the Falcon,
the Winter Soldier series,
there's also the question of what happens
to a new Clark guy, a character.
Like I said in previous videos,
she probably winds up taking her father,
Taylor's place as Nick Fury's right
hand person working for him on the Saber
space station, being kind of like
a version of Abigail Brand in the MCU,
but not actual Abigail Brand.
the funny thing about that
is that her extremist base powers are her
fire based powers actually look little bit
similar to Abigail Brand's powers
I don't know if she has a cameo
during the Marvel's movie, though.
We'll see.
I'm not expecting her
to show up in that movie.
that the world knows
about the rest of the skrulls too.
There's the question
of what happens to them.
They probably get to continue
living on earth
and they have this line in the previous
episode about how they like the cold
they might come to a compromise
with the World Security Council
where they allow them to live in
just a really cold place on Earth
that humans have a hard time living,
like send the skrulls to Antarctica.
It's not like a whole bunch of humans
are going to want to live there
instead of them.
there will be a funny way
to reveal the savage land in the MCU.
It exists in Antarctica, in the comics.
But everyone posts all your theories
for the finale in the comments below,
and I'll post my full episode
six video next week after they release it
in, like I said, couple of big Comic-Con
trailers coming the next couple of days.
Make sure to enable orders for my channel
and I'll post those videos
as quickly as possible.
we should be getting that Marvel's trailer
either later tonight or tomorrow
at some point.
the maybe a Loki season
two trailer this weekend.
And I think we're also getting
an invincible season two trailer two
if you have not watched any of the
invincible episodes, it's amazing.
Be sure to check it out because Steven
Yeun plays the invincible character.
He's also probably going
to be playing the new MCU version
of the century in the Thunderbolts movie.
click here for that brand new trailer.
I the link as soon as I post it
and click here for all my Secret Invasion
episode videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!